Hey everyone, it's Mike from Orderflows,
and in this presentation I'm going to
show you how to improve your trading
using the 10 features of Orderflows
Trader. You know, one of the questions I
get asked a lot is what makes the
Orderflows Trader different than say the
volumetric bars on NinjaTrader, or you
know, say, you know, any of the other
Orderflows software that's out there.
And actually what we've done with the
Orderflows Trader, the reason why it was
created is because I want to take my
form of Orderflow analysis and put it
into the software so that the software
will help you with your analysis rather
than just presenting you with a basic
volume footprint chart. Now, before I
begin, you know, brief disclaimer, don't
trade with money you can't afford to
lose. You know, and unfortunately, you
know, a lot of people still fall into
that trap. They they think that, oh, you
know what, I've got I got a big bill due
at the end of the month. I want to start
trading. I want to learn how to trade in
in a day or so. It's it's not that easy,
you know, you got to put in the time and
the effort. And what I'm about to show
you will take you out of your comfort
zone, but if you wish to be a better
trader, then you should want to get out
of your comfort zone. And but let me ask
you, you know, are you willing to put in
the work to become a better trader and
give yourself
the freedom in life that you deserve.
You know, trading is a business which
can help your bottom line when you
improve your skills. And the Orderflows
Trader software, in my opinion, will
take majority of the traders
from point A to point B in the quickest
way possible without going down a lot of
blind alleys. Now, I'm not going to say
it's going to take every trader and, you
know, get them across the finish line.
No, because, you know, there's some
people just aren't made for trading. Um,
you know, that's that's a cold, hard
truth, but, you know, not everybody is
cut out for trading. You know, just as
not everybody is cut out to be a doctor
or a nurse even. You know, my wife is a
nurse, but me, you know, if I if I got
to look at blood and guts, you know, no,
thank you. You know, I'll look for
something else to do. Um, it's going to
be like, "Excuse me while I go vomit."
But, you know, for those that are new to
this presentation and new to Orderflows,
um, just quick background about me.
You know, and I know I I'm not doing
this to say, "Hey, look at me, you know,
I I've done this in my life." No, I'm
doing this so you understand that what
I'm talking about comes from real life
experience. You know, in 2015, I started
up orderflows.com.
But prior to that, from 2006 to 2012, I
was vice president of futures trading at
JP Morgan. You know, JP Morgan, right?
The one of the top banks in the world.
2002 to 2005, I ran the futures and
options trading desk at Cargill, both in
Chicago and eventually in Singapore.
From 1998 to 2001, I was a licensed
Eurex trader at Commerzbank. You know,
now the German banks are under a lot of
uh
under a lot of pressure, but you know,
back in the in the '90s, you know, the
the German banks were the world's
leaders.
97 to 98, I was with EDF Man as a global
macro trader. In 1994, I started on the
CME floor with Dean Witter. Eventually,
I left the floor when electronic trading
started to
um become popular. And you know, I've
been in the trenches, you know, and and
this is just what we had to deal with
back in the '90s, right? This is um
the order book
on Eurodollars. You know, you can see
how how it looked, you know, compared to
what you're looking at nowadays, you
know,
things have changed. You know, this was
the ticker. This is what a ticker looked
like on uh Globex. This was a ticker.
This was E-minis. This was 20 years ago.
This was the ESU um 1998 contract. And
um this is project A, which was the
Board of Trade's ticker for um bonds, 10
years, you know, in the grain market,
the electronically traded market. The
nice thing about it, which was a great
feature, you could see who the buyer and
sellers were. You know, I mean, not the
individuals, but you could see what firm
they were buying and selling from. Um I
forgot what house 100 is. You know, it's
IC3 is is the member number. Um and IU
at 560. 560, I believe was Merrill
Lynch. It's
you're talking 20 years ago. My I don't
remember the house numbers, but you
know, certain ones I know 980 was Dean
Witter.
Um you know, and
um you know, 560 I believe was Merrill
Lynch. And you know, in all those years,
I've discovered there's no holy grail in
trading, you know. Honestly, the closest
you're going to get to a holy grail in
trading is becoming a consistent trader,
right? There there's no one perfect
entry and exit, you know, I mean, people
like to look at textbook examples and
I'm going to show you some examples um
you know, of of what trade setups look
like, but you got to remember
every trade is going to be looking
slightly different than the other. And
really, the most closest you're going to
get to perfection, there is no
perfection in trading, is becoming
consistent in your trading.
And you know, the best chance you'll
have as a trader is to learn what makes
the market move, and that's order flow.
And the best way to do it is to learn
from someone who has already proven
their success with it, you know. Again,
I've spent 20 years at the top firms in
the industry, in the trading business,
you know, so it's not like, well, I just
started trading um 6 years ago and 2
years ago I I discovered order flow and
now I'm going to teach it. No, you know,
this is what I did. This is what paid my
bills, you know, paid for my house, paid
for my car, everything, you know. This
is This was my That was my job.
Now, when I created the order flows
trader, you know, there were very few
order flow volume footprint software out
there at the time, you know, this is 5
years ago, more or less. And you know,
and off,
which I don't really understand the
name, Ninja order flow traders traders,
um OFA, order flow advantage, I think
it's called advantage. Um Rancho Dinero,
which is what I used for a while. Market
Delta I've also tried. It's
unfortunately it's gone out of business.
And Golmi, basically that was it back
then.
And in 2011, you know, honestly, that
was good enough, you know, just as an
Nokia phone was good enough back in in
in the day, you know, um 20 years ago,
but it's not
10 years ago. It's not 2011. It's not
2000. It's 2019. You know, you're not
using the Nokia phone anymore, right?
You're using
the latest iPhone most likely or you
know, iPhone from last year, but you're
you've updated it, right? And as a
trader, you should be updating um you
know, the way that you're trading, the
way that you're looking at the market.
And the whole reason for creating the
Order Flows um Trader software is
because I wanted something better. I
wanted something that's going to help me
see the nuances in the order flow, you
know, the things that I was looking for
to trade around every day. So, I found a
programmer who understood order flow,
right? And we created the Order Flows
Trader in 2013. In 2015, I released it
to the public
only after a lot of other traders that I
was just talking with um you know, said,
"Hey, you know, can I get a copy?" And
you know, then they then start telling
me, "Hey, you know, you could um maybe
start a business like this." And you
know, that's how it That's how it came
up, you know, it came up from my own
personal tool to a lot of people asking
um me for it. So, what made the Order
Flows Trader different was that it
highlighted things happening in the
order flow that mattered. Now, the Order
Flows Trader, it runs on Ninja Trader 8.
I don't support the Ninja Trader 7
version anymore, so don't ask it for it.
And it'll run on both the free and paid
versions of Ninja Trader. Okay, now I
understand that Ninja Trader does have
their own order flow chart um on their
fully paid licensed version, which
you're going to spend you know, whatever
a thousand bucks for or more. Um but
that's just a basic order flow chart and
maybe one or two little extra tools or
something, but
it's
just a basic chart. And you're paying a
lot of money for that. So, you know,
the Order Flows Trader will run on the
free version of Ninja Trader. You know,
I have users that
get my software,
get the free version of Ninja Trader,
and they use their own broker provided
um front end, you know, whether it's
Sierra Chart or um you know, some of
these other, you know, depending on who
your broker is, you know, all brokers
offer you a free order entry um
software. And that's what some of my
users are doing because they understand
the value in the Order Flows Trader.
Now, if you want to trade with the
NinjaTrader version, then yeah, by all
means get a
paid version of NinjaTrader.
I'm not trying to promote NinjaTrader
brokerage or anything, but um you know,
the Order Flows Trader will also work on
that system. So,
again, I'm not trying to promote
NinjaTrader or NinjaTrader brokerage,
but my software does run on NinjaTrader.
So, in the first release of Order Flows
Trader in 2015,
we had the ratios, which I highlight the
areas of price rejection or price
defense. Um we also had single prints,
which highlight price exhaustion or
price rejection.
Um we had delta divergence, which
highlights when price and order flows
diverge. We had unfinished business,
which highlight areas the market may
come back to. We had imbalance reversal,
which highlighted trap traders. We had
volume profile, which allows a trader to
see how the day is developing. Now, last
year,
I released the Order Flows Trader 2.0,
and this was a big um upgrade from the
original Order Flows Trader, which was
for NinjaTrader 7. This was for
NinjaTrader 8 that we released it for
straight to um NinjaTrader 8.
And it has all those tools I just
described, but we improved the tools,
the existing tools, and we've added
more, you know, so it's like basically
taken, you know, the engine that's
working and we souped it up. And in the
new version, we added we've improved the
imbalance reversals tool to highlight
additional areas of trap traders.
We added a zero print indicator to show
when markets flipped.
We added four ladder types, bid ask,
delta volume, diagonal delta. We added
POC trader, which was actually a
separate indicator that I would sell for
$200, which highlights prominent point
of controls. We added a volume imbalance
box which highlight multiple imbalances
in a bar that are not stacked on top of
each other. And you know, the multiple
imbalances is is a great tool that
really
helps a lot of traders. So, I'm going to
explain the 10 most important features
of the Order Flows Trader and how to use
them to find low-risk trading
opportunities, market reversals, confirm
trend directions, and much more. So,
what are they? Well,
yeah, these are in no particular order.
So, don't don't think you know any you
know because one is ranked number one,
it's it's better. No, these there's no
particular order in here on how I put
it. So, the first one is the Order Flows
Delta Divergence, Order Flows Imbalance
Reversals, four different ladder types,
POC Trader, Small Digit Prints, Summary
Content, Unfinished Business, Volume
Imbalance, Volume Profile, and Volume
Ratio.
And again, you know, I can't stress this
enough. What makes the Order Flows
Trader different from the rest of the
other order flow trading software out
there is it's designed by a trader for
traders. You know, all of the tools I
just mentioned are what I use in
trading.
You know, they're not just added to make
it look like software has a lot of
features, right? Each feature is added
specifically for use in seeing something
in the order flow, right? I I I don't
just add things into the software that
oh, you know, this other software has it
so I want it. I want to put it in there.
No, you know, if it's something that if
it's a form of analysis or a tool that I
use in my trading, I want to put it in
there. You know, it's like that scene in
Fast not Fast and Furious, in XXX, the
one with Vin Diesel where you know, he's
the skateboarder that becomes a um
you know, spy. And you know, he's got
the little tech guy and you know,
they're going to raid the castle and
he's got his
car
and you know, on the on the table next
to it is all these
weapons, you know, all these bazooka,
rocket launcher, machine guns. He tells
the guy, "I want all of that in there."
and he points to the car. It's it's the
same way with the Order Flows Trader,
right? I take all the tools that I would
normally use in my trading, or in my
case, you know, the way I would look at
order flow,
and put it into the software.
Now, you know, Steve Jobs, right? We all
know who Apple is, right? We all most of
us got iPhones or or Macs and
everything.
Steve Jobs is brilliant. Why? It's
because, you know, he thinks
differently, right? He didn't invent the
mobile phone. You know, mobile phones
have been around for
a long time before he released the
iPhone, but what he did is he took all
the, you know, the technology that was
available to him, and he made the phone
better, right? You know, cameras people
don't carry around cameras so much
anymore, unless they're like
professional photographer.
Pretty much everybody just takes their
pictures with their phone, right? And,
you know, it's even getting to the point
where it's hard,
you know, you want to buy a computer,
there's very few computer stores around
anymore. Why? It's because everyone is
doing using a tablet, or they're using
their phone to access the internet and
and do work. You know, people don't have
You know, people have computers,
especially for trading, but I'm saying,
you know,
the market's gotten much smaller
because, you know, the other markets
have expanded, right? The phones and
tablet business has expanded, and it's
it's crushing out the competitors. And
again, you know, I'm not
trying to invent the phone. I'm just
taking what's out there and making it
better.
So,
the thing to keep in mind with order
flow is you're not looking at everything
at once, right? To me, order flow is
reactionary trading. It's not predatory
trading. You know, when something
happens in the order flow, I react. You
know, I'm reacting to what's happening
right now based on buying and selling by
market participants. All right, so let's
just jump into it now. Um you know,
that's a
That's kind of a long introduction.
But, so the first thing you're going to
have to do is, you know, after you
purchase the Order Flows Trader, is you
have to import it into NinjaTrader 8 and
enter your license token, which you're
sent after purchasing the software. Now,
it can take, you know, they're manually
created, so it can take um
you know, it can take a little while,
but you know, you should get it within,
you know, a couple hours at the latest.
So,
what you're going to do is go to come on
email, and once you've already installed
the um
you you import the OrderFlows Trader
into NinjaTrader, you just go to a
chart, click on indicators,
click on the OrderFlows Trader, you'll
see it come down here. And the first
thing is here, your license token. You
just copy and paste it from your email
and drop it in there and click apply,
and that's it.
Okay, so, the first thing I'll talk
about is delta divergence.
Now, a delta divergence occurs when
price and order flow diverge from each
other. You know, a delta divergence sell
occurs when price makes a new or equal
high, but order flow delta is negative.
You know, a delta divergence buy occurs
when a price makes a new or equal low,
and delta is positive. All right, now,
I'm not going to get into the
intricacies of what is delta here.
Hopefully by now you should understand
that, you know, watch, you know, just go
to my YouTube channel, I've got a ton of
other videos on um the basics of order
flow. So, what makes the OrderFlows
delta divergence improved over the
standard delta divergence is that it
also takes into account price action.
You know, delta divergence indicates
a possible reversal, but if the market
isn't showing signs of reversal, then
the signal isn't going to be very
effective, right? And OrderFlows delta
divergence takes price action into
account, while a normal delta divergence
does not. And that's important, because,
you know, if you're trading a reversal,
you got to have a move to reverse,
right? You got to be at a high,
you know, if to to if you're going to
reverse it, right? If you're going to
look to be selling, you know, you should
be at a high area, not a low area. And
you can see up here, the circles, you
know, these little triangles up here are
delta OrderFlows delta divergence.
I didn't put the circle up here, but
it's right up in here, right here at the
top here.
On the bottom.
You know, this is what a buy looks like
down here. And, you know, look at this,
right? He had a sell up here at the high
of the day.
Sold off, made new lows, made new lows,
made new lows, and look what you got at
the low.
An order flows divergence. So,
you know,
again, now I'm not saying, you know,
every time you have a order flows
divergence that looks like this where it
goes from the high to the low, you know,
and makes new lows until it finds a new
delta divergence.
Um, you know, in this case it just
happened to.
You know, but anytime you're up here at
a high or at a low, you should be asking
yourself, you know, are there signs of a
reversal? And having a order flows
divergence is the start of a good sign,
you know, you should start taking other
things in context. You know, what's
happening with price action, what's
happening with delta
overall rather than just analyzing one
single bar. You know, you should take in
market structure to account. You know,
that that's what's going to give you
these powerful trades where you sell off
from high of the day to new lows, new
lows down to an area where you've got
another
a bullish divergence this time and the
market runs up. Now,
when an order flows delta divergence
occurs with an order flows ratio, which
is something I'll talk about later in
this in this presentation, the result is
a powerful trade setup. I'll just show
you really quick.
So, down here, right? You've got your
divergence. That's this green triangle.
And you see this number, it's a blue
number, 0.5278.
This is what I call a bullish ratio.
It's at the bottom of the bar, it's
underneath the bar, and it's blue color,
right? You'll see some numbers are
black, some numbers are blue under the
bars or above the bars.
If it's blue, it's a ratio that I like.
It's very bullish if it's below the bar.
If it's above the red bar, then it's a
bearish number. If it's a black number,
like you see here, that's just your
normal order flow going through.
And again, you know, this is something
that I'll talk about later in this
presentation. You know, here's another
example. You know, here you have a
divergence that failed. You made a new
low by a tick. And then you got down
here, you've got your divergence, and
you got your bullish ratio. And you see
how the market made a nice
um rally. This is in the bonds. You
know, you rally from
you know, 153 uh
you know,
05 06. You know, all the way up to 153
20. And, you know, how fast, you know,
it's a 5-minute chart. It took up all of
about, you know,
an hour.
So, the next thing I'll talk about is
imbalance reversals. And imbalance
reversals
actually has two indicators built in,
and their purpose is to highlight bars
where traders are trapped, and bars
where market sweeps are occurring. You
know, we we we put them both under
imbalance reversals. So, the first part
I'll talk about
is um
the uh trapped traders, right? When an a
form of trapped traders is an imbalance
reversal. And an imbalance reversal
occurs when traders are long and wrong,
or short in the hole. We've all heard
that expression, "Oh, I'm long and
wrong."
And that's what this uh tool helps you
find out. You know, are traders long and
wrong?
Now,
you may want to keep the colors
different. You know, the default is red
and green for both uh
imbalance reversals and zero prints.
So, in this example, I changed it to a
dark orange and dark blue. Okay?
Now, a zero print indicator
indicates when a market sweep occurred
at the edge of a bar. And this is
important because a market sweep is a
clear sign of extra aggressive buying or
extra aggressive selling occurring. It's
especially important
for market turning points when they are
occurring at swing highs or swing lows.
You know, not just highs or lows of the
day, but at swing highs and swing lows.
And what a sweep is, okay, when when I
talk about a market sweep, say the
market is trading six bid at seven.
Okay, I and I'm a big trader, right?
I've I've got
a portfolio that I got a, you know, or
I've got an allocation of 20 of
$300 million, okay? And I think, well,
crude oil is going up. Okay, I need to
buy 1,000 contracts. Okay, so I check
the market. Market six bid at seven.
Well, I see I could buy
500 contracts all the way up to 09. So,
I just lift the offer. I just buy, you
know, I just enter it buy 500 up to 09.
And I just sweep the market up there
like that. That's what a sweep is.
And it's very bullish if it's to the
upside and it's very bearish if it's to
the downside. So,
excuse me.
Imbalance reversals that trap traders,
right? You can see here, right? I have
have changed the colors.
It's
for us a sell, it's going to be dark
orange. For a buy, it's going to be dark
blue.
Okay, so you can see here, right? It's
orange, orange, orange. These are all
indications of trapped traders. And you
can see here
how the market is going down. And people
say, well, market's going down, why you
got trapped traders trying to buy it?
Well, you know,
as the market is selling off, you still
have people thinking, hey, you know
what, this is a great buying
opportunity. We're coming down into the
lows and they're buying it, right? They
they they think that the market's going
to go back up. But what's happening is
there's downward pressure, you know,
there's offers coming into the market
holding that market down.
And then boom, the the floor just drops
out right over here.
Okay?
Here's uh trapped traders again.
This is uh crude oil.
All right. And you can see here, right?
The blue,
the orange. You get these nice little
pop up, this nice little pop down.
Here's some more. This is Nasdaq at
5-minute chart.
Blue arrow, blue arrow.
Orange arrow, blue arrow. You know, we
got this nice move up, we got this nice
move up, we got this nice move down.
Now, people
will say,
"Oh, yeah, yeah, you told me you had
trap traders here and I bought and the
market didn't go anywhere." Well,
you really should have taken your signal
earlier.
Um and yeah, take it in market context,
you know? Do you want to be buying going
into the high, you know?
If you're at a high, you got to be
looking for a potential reason to sell.
Just as you're you're at a swing low,
doesn't actually have to be the exact
swing low, you could be somewhere near
your swing low, look for a reason to
buy.
All right? Down here, you know, would I
be looking at trap traders
to get short down in here? No, you know,
realistically, the better trade is to
look to be getting long as the market
goes back up.
Now, zero prints, right? A sweep, a
market sweep, right? Like I was telling
you here, it's usually an indicative,
the first sign
clearer sign is a lot of zeros.
Um you know, now
you could see here,
right? This is a stacked imbalance.
Now,
you don't always get a stacked
imbalance, but this is just very clear.
You know, someone just came in and sold
about 250 contracts from basically, you
know, 40
47 all the way down to 40. You know, his
average price is going to be, you know,
somewhere around here, 44.
But that's what a sweep looks like.
Here it is on the upside.
Okay?
Now, in this case,
it's not as, you know, full of zeros as
it is here, right? You got like four
price levels with zeros. Here you got
thinner volume, you know, 4 7 11 0.
But again, you know, this is what a
sweep looks like in here. Someone just
buying up whatever offers are there
in anticipation of higher prices.
Okay, so that's zero prints and that's
um trap traders, you know, imbalance
reversals we call them on the software.
Now,
you know, the next thing I'll talk about
is the ladder content. Now, most people
are familiar with looking at a bid ask
order flow chart and
you know, that's what I recommend most
people to look at, but you know, that we
have other charts that you can look at.
You can also look at delta.
You can look at total volume
at a price level and you can also look
at diagonal delta.
Now,
the two that I use the most, well, the
most I use is is bid ask and second one
is delta. Okay? I don't use so much
volume and I don't use uh diagonal
delta, but it's there, you know, if it
fits into your trading plan. So, what
you do, it's right in here, right? Under
ladder content.
You see here sell text. The first one is
bid ask. What you're going to do is
you're going to click on it if you want
to change it and you can see there's a
drop-down menu. You get bid ask, delta,
volume, and diagonal delta. Just choose
the one you want. So, you know, the
normal bid ask you can see here, right?
You can see the the volume trade on the
bid, the volume trade on the offer, and
you're going to be able to see um you
know, the actual numbers that traded,
right? You're going to see what the
actual imbalances were, you know, the
volumes and everything. You know, it's
very revealing
for traders, you know.
Honestly, when I
first saw an order flow chart, I was
just like,
"Nah, do I do I need that information?"
Then as I spent more time with it, I
can't look at a normal bar chart and
trade off of it
you know, with any consistency. But,
with an order flow chart,
I I my trading makes sense, all right? I
mean, you know, I can look at a bar
chart. There's certain things that I'll
I'll look for on a bar chart, you know,
like your engulfing pattern or something
like that, but
you know, with an order flow trader, we
have candlesticks on here. So, I can see
all that, but I can also see that, you
know, on this outside engulf this
outside bar this engulfing pattern, I
can see, "Oh my gosh, you know, I know I
had heavier volume up here."
You know, which is bearish, right? Like
this is a prominent point of control,
which I'll talk about next. You know, I
could feel safer in taking this sell
than, you know, taking, you know, some
other sells from earlier, right? Can't
really see um
you know, many sell reasons to be
getting short on this way up on this
chart. But, you know, how many times,
you know, people always talk about, you
know, when candlesticks came out, you
know, everyone thought this is, you
know, that's the greatest thing since
sliced bread. You know, everyone just
sort of migrated to them
until they realized that
you know, candlesticks work
sometimes and they don't work a lot of
times. So,
you know, if you can
have a pattern that you're familiar
with, that makes sense to you. Like,
okay, yeah, I like to trade engulfing
patterns because, you know, what that
means, it tells me that you know, what's
going on in the price action
is significant in the sense that, you
know, we we've moved from, you know, the
range of the bar that we're in is bigger
than the previous bar. So, it tells me
more traders are getting active. I mean,
it should. Um
that, you know, there's a chance the
market can continue down. Now, when I
start adding order flow to it, like
here, I got a prominent point of
control.
Um I could, you know, I could look at
the volumes. I could see, well, the
volume is good, it's decent, you know.
Um yeah, it just gives you more
confidence in the trade that you're
going to take. Now, delta content is
what delta looks like, right? What it
does, it takes the horizontal delta, the
linear delta. So, you can see on this
bar right here at the high um
30 on the top of this red candle, right?
And what that is, that's the volume
here, 24 minus 54, and it's on the offer
side. So, cuz the offer side traded 54
contracts, the bid side only traded um
24.
So, the difference is 30, so it appears
here. The price level below it, it's 110
against 130. So, that's 20 on the uh
on the offer side here, it's 102 minus
67. 102 is This is more.
Um so, what's that difference? 102 minus
67 is what? 35. So, that's That'll be 35
on the bid side, right? So, you can see
here, right? 30 20 minus 35. That's what
a delta chart looks like.
And in a delta ladder, there are
patterns. Okay? There are patterns that
you can
see inside here.
Okay, now I'm not going to get into all
the little patterns, but you know, I
actually have a course on specifically
on delta. And there are setups that I
talk about that you can see here um on a
delta chart. Now, the volume
it just takes the volume, the linear
volume at each price level, and adds it
together. So, you can see up here, this
is 78 240 169.
24 plus 54 is 78. Um
240 is uh the 110 plus 130. And um 169
is the 102 plus 67, right? You can see
it just right there. It all puts it on
one side. It doesn't put it on in the
middle or, you know, on on the left-hand
side. It's all on the left-hand side,
not the right-hand side or the middle.
You can't change that.
But, even with that, you know, there are
there are things, you know, for some
people that
you can use that information, right?
Like, for example,
say you're you know, you're looking at
this bar, right? You can see here, oh my
gosh, you know, I have the high here.
You know, it's a red candle, so it
closed lower. But, what's the volume
like up here at the top? Is it heavy?
78, yeah, that's decent, you know, 240
169. Okay.
You know, you might look at that and
say, well, you know, that's you know,
is that enough for a reversal? Yeah,
maybe. You know, down here, right? You
can see as we're coming down, you know,
we got these this these three bars right
around the same level. You can look at
the volume here at how heavy it is.
And just going across, you know, 400,
447, 464, 179, 758, 300, 329, 762, 11,
265, 691, 409. So, I know at this area
there's support. There's there's
there's a lot of
active trading going on down here that
we couldn't get past that.
Right? This would be a support level. I
would watch it for the next time we come
back here. And you can see as we came
right back to it, where's the support
coming in? It's coming in right at that
same level, 6030. So, if I'm short from
up here, where's my target going to be?
It's going to be at this level here,
right around 6030. So, if I'm short at
60, you know, 6050,
you know, my first target's going to be
6030.
You know, the problem that a lot of
traders have
is, you know, they they use these
arbitrary
um take profits and
and stop losses without realizing that
you know, the
the area that where they're going to,
you know, say they're
say their take profit is going to be,
you know, 30 ticks. Well, if you're
short at 6050, 6020 is down here, but I
know, you know, around the 6030 area
there's support from earlier. You know,
I got to get through that. It may not be
realistic to get through. You know, you
may have to take your profits a little
bit early.
Okay? And you know, that's how, if
you're looking at volume, that how that
can help you in your trading. Now,
diagonal delta is the delta,
you know,
diagonally, basically, off the uh
bid-ask chart. Again, I don't I don't
use it. I I don't really have a need for
it. Um I find the delta one very
powerful.
Obviously, the bid-ask one is um decent.
Most people is it's good enough. If you
want to delve a little bit more inside
the footprint chart, go with a delta
chart, All all right?
The
bid ask footprint is seen inside the
bar, so to speak, seen inside the
candlestick, whereas the delta one I
think gets you inside the footprint,
okay?
Now, another part of the ladder content
is you can view up to three POC levels,
point of controls, right? Point of
control is the price level where the
most volume occurred. And
you can also view the second level with
the most volume and the third level with
the most volume. Most people won't use
these, but let me just show you what it
looks like.
This is the standard one
point of control, right? Each bar every
bar has a point of control. Every bar
has got two point of controls. So, what
you could do is, you know, if you want
you can change the colors.
Don't keep them all the same. Um, you
know, ideally you should color code
them.
You can change, you know,
yellow and
green. The You can see the black one,
that's the outline of the rectangle. You
can also change that, but you can keep
it the same. So, like yellow, green, and
red.
And this is what it looks like here.
You know, so you it's kind of light it
up a bit more.
What do I got? Yellow, green, and red
gray.
Oh, this one.
Oh, why did I didn't change it there.
But, you get the idea, right? So, you
can play around with that. And there are
patterns even within, you know, when
you're looking at three point of
controls.
You know, a nice point of control setup
just really quick is when they're spaced
out like this.
When yeah, you got uh you your top point
of control up here, you know, a middle
point of control in the middle, and one
down here at the bottom. You know,
that's that's telling you that price is
migrating lower. I mean, obviously price
is going down, it's a red candle, but
the value areas are getting down as well
as you know, sometimes you see them
bunched up at the bottom of a green bar
or you know, at the top of a red bar.
When you see that, that's also very
powerful. Again, I got I've got a
separate course on point of control, if
you know, if you really want to delve
into point of controls, but for most
people, you know, the standard one level
POC is enough, right? I last thing I
want people to do is is throw everything
in the kitchen sink on their charts. Um
use the pieces of order flow that are
going to be uh useful to you.
Now, the PLC trader, now this is
something that I sold separately
actually with
um
NinjaTrader 7, but a NinjaTrader 8, I
said, you know, I need this in my
software. And it was actually it's
actually better because
as opposed to the separate indicator
because the separate indicator just
highlights the bar, you know, it'll draw
up and down arrow, whereas this one will
actually color the point of control,
whatever colors I want, you know, I like
cyan. I I don't differentiate the levels
cuz I got eyes, I could tell if it's a
level one, level two, level three, I'll
show you in a second.
But you can see up to three levels,
right? Now, if
if your chart is a shorter term chart,
like say you're looking at a four range
chart, you're only going to want to look
at level one and level two cuz level
three on a four range chart is going to
be right in the middle of the bar.
Okay, so you know, if you're looking at
say an eight range chart or a minute
chart on you know, like say Nasdaq or
mini Dow, yeah, you going to want to
look at three levels. If you look at a
minute chart on
S&Ps, you minis rather, you know, it
depends on uh
you know, the the time of day, you know,
during the cash session, you you do get
a little bit longer bars, especially
recently um with all the volatility in
the market, but you know, normally, you
know, if you if you're getting bars that
are routinely, you know, five price
levels or less, you know, stick to the
two levels, but if it's, you know, more
volatile market, you could expand it to
three levels. So, what you do is again,
you could change the distances one, two,
and three.
That's the distance from the top or the
bottom. That's what the the maximum POC
distance is.
And you could have the colors. I I like
to keep all the colors the same cuz it's
just easier. I I don't want to sit here
and try and decide, oh, you know, if I
change this to a green color and this to
a blue and that to, you know, a black
color. It's it's a little it's too
confusing for me, you know, I'm
I'm getting older. I I like to keep
things simple. And you can see here,
right? This is a bearish prominent point
of control.
Right? You see all the other point of
controls are just your normal gray
color, right? Every bar has a point of
control, but not every point of control
is going to matter. And that's what the
POC trader does is it highlights the
ones that are important, the ones that
are going to act as support or
resistance.
You can see here on this move up,
nothing here.
It's all gray point of controls, right?
You get down in here. You got some blue
point of control, a blue point of
control. These are support areas. You
can see how the market bounced off of
each of these point of controls. Here
you got a bearish point of control. The
market came right back up though,
unfortunately. Um
What what time was this? Is this
E-minis? This is at
It's at 3:30 in the afternoon when
they're closing.
So, but anyway, you can see how you
know, the point I'm trying to make is
how they act as support or resistance
most of the time.
And
again, you know, this is the point I was
trying to make if you're trading bars
that are short, you got to be careful.
Like here's four price levels, here's
four price levels. Here's four price
levels, here's four price levels.
What I mean by four price levels is this
bar only traded four different price
levels. So,
you know, you you only got one in four
places for the the prominent point of
control to come in. It's probably not
going to be
as effective as, you know, if you're
using so, you know, bar that's got
you know, a bigger range.
But again, you know, that's something
you're going to have to deal with
yourself. You got to make that decision.
You know, me personally, I I don't look
at bars that are less than than four
price levels. Um, cuz you know, it's
it's hard to get any meaningful
um, analysis out of bars that are very
short where you're basically trading the
bid offer plus one tick or minus one
tick.
You know, it's basically a sideways
market is is what small price bars give
you.
So like I here's uh, mini Dow, right?
It's a 1-minute chart. You see, you got
Look at this prominent point of control
right up here, right? Big move up. You
got to move to reverse. You got a
bearish prominent point of control right
here. And you know, over the next two
bars, you know, you move
you know, 25 ticks. Basically, this this
one bar is this big down bar is 25
ticks.
You know, you even went lower, but
that's your bearish sign here. And you
can see how this market sold off. It
rallied back up. Where did it rally to?
It rallied right up to this prominent
point of control.
And then came off again. You know, I'm
not saying, you know, you you for some
people, I know that there's
at least one guy.
He what he does is he has, you know,
when he sees a prominent point of
control like this, he throws an offer
up here.
And he just has a stop couple ticks
away.
You know, he gets stopped out a lot, but
you know, he's willing to to lose two or
three ticks on a quick trade to get, you
know, 20 ticks, 30 ticks out of the
trade over the next couple of bars.
Again, you know,
for a lot of you know,
trading is about risk and reward. You
know, if you could have a trade plan
that says, "Okay, I'm going to get short
at a retest of a prominent point of
control. I'm going to risk two ticks on
this trade, but my potential profit is
20 ticks. I'm risking two to get 20.
Okay. And I know that I'm going to I'm
going to lose about, you know, 70% of my
trades, 75% even 80. You know, I'm fine
with it because
over the long run, I'm going to be
successful. So, again, you know, that's
how you would use prominent point of
controls. You can use them as support
and resistance when you see them occur
and you can trade around them. You know,
you see them forming,
you know, you see bullish prominent
point of controls, these blue ones here.
I start investigating, you know, should
I be getting long? Okay. Well, let me
see what's going on in the delta. Let me
see what's going on in the imbalances.
You know, what's going on in the overall
price action and market structure
of the day. You know, put start putting
the pieces together.
Now, small digit prints. This is a
legacy indicator. This is something that
we had in the original version of Order
Flows Trader and it highlights bars that
have price rejection or what some people
now call price exhaustion at the edge of
a bar. It's great for reversals and
confirming trend direction. And you see
it's right here. It's called the small
digit prints.
There's a box here. You can enter the
number.
For bullish ones, it's going to be light
green. For bearish ones, it's going to
be red. And you could
adjust the opacity. All right, you don't
want to make it 100% cuz then you're not
going to be able to see the value in
there, the number in the in the
footprint. So, I have it set as default
to 50. Um
and you'll see what it looks like in a
second. Now, you can adjust this, right?
It doesn't have to be nine.
You know, if you're trading a very
liquid market like say 10 years, you
might want to set it to 50. You know,
each bar in the 10 years, supposing
you're looking at a four range chart,
you know, a bar in the 10 years on a
four range chart could be 30,000
contracts. So, trying to limit it to
nine may not be small. Well, it's nine
is small, but you may be willing to say,
well, you know, 25 is also small, so you
could change it to 25. So, when I say
it's great for reversals and confirming
trend, let me just show you here.
So, what do I got here? This is this
Well, is the 10-years, right? You see
two, right? Right in here, okay? And
you know, here you got seven, here you
got five, okay? So, this market is going
down, right? This is just telling me,
you know, if I'm already short
that
I'm seeing price rejection here. I'm
seeing price rejection here.
Now, again, you could also call it price
exhaustion. What's happening is this
market's selling off, selling off, and
down here nobody's interested in trading
down here. Two lots trade. Normally, in
the 10-years at each price level, you
know, it could be anywhere between 500
and 5,000. You see the volume, 8,000,
4,000, 3,000, 2,000, 759,
and two lots only?
You know, so that's how you're going to
get your reversal signal, right? Here
you go. This is 10-years high of the
day, five lots trade. Five lots trade in
the 10-years. Look at this bar. You're
trading This bar traded 75
73,000 contracts, but traded just five
lots at that high.
Okay? That should be a signal to you to
say nobody's interested in buying these
highs up here taking the market higher.
You see how the market just came off
beautifully? You know, if you're trading
with a dome, this is I used to trade
with a dome. I don't anymore.
Um
You know, and and the reason is is
you know, I sort of
like to think I took a step back in my
trading. You know, I wanted something
more relaxed than looking at a dome and
and each and every tick, but
one of the reasons why I had this put in
in the original version is because I
when I would look at a dome, I would
specifically, cuz I traded bonds a lot
back then as well,
I would be looking for these bars, you
know, at highs of days, lows of days,
swing highs, swing lows, where there was
a single print or small print appearing
and trade against it. So, I know, oh my
god, I got a single print up here. You
know, at five contracts. You know, like
down here you got 73. You might think 73
is small. You could adjust it. You could
bust this number out from 9 to 100,
okay?
But, you know, it's set to 9. So, if I
see this print up here, five, and I just
start ticking down, ticking down, I know
I could fade that. You know, I could You
know, I could try to scalp. This is why
I don't trade a dome cuz, you know,
trading a dome, you know, everyone's is
it's happy days if you get scalped three
ticks. You know, I want more than three
ticks. That's why I don't really look at
a dome anymore. Nothing against domes,
you know, I spent a lot of time in my
career trading on a dome. But, uh my
trading has become a little bit more
longer term.
But, this is why I I put it in there is
because I would look for these areas
where I was seeing this price
exhaustion, you know, this lack of
buying interest up here, right? I mean,
I know, Tom DeMark told me many years
ago,
you know, highs are made when people are
done buying.
You know, when the last buyer has
bought, the high is put in, right? And
you can see here, five. The last buyers
have bought, the high is put in.
And now let's look out below.
Here's bonds.
Okay, so this is what I was talking
about on uh confirming market direction,
right? Now, it's going to appear at the
bottom of a green bar on the bid side or
the top of a red bar on the offer side.
So, look at this, right? I got a low
here, okay? And I say you know, even
though I got a ratio and divergence,
which is two bullish things, but I'm
getting long and I see it the move
trailed by uh single prints, you know,
I'm fairly confident in this move that
traders aren't interested in selling um
the market back down into the lows. So,
if I'm long and I start seeing single
prints appearing, that's what I like to
see on a move, right? Uh that helps me
stay in the trade longer, right? Even
though I got a bearish ratio right here,
you know, the fact that it's followed,
you know, this bullish signal here is
followed by, you know, this two single
small prints is telling me, you know
what?
You can probably hold it a little bit
longer. Obviously, I got the imbalances
in here as well.
Um
you know, but you can start putting
these pieces together in your analysis.
You know, here you got your seven here,
right? You got your nine here, your
bearish number, right? As the market
keeps going down. You know, you you you
pop your you hit your highest sell-off,
start rallying back up. I know I got
this nine here, okay?
Well,
you know, that's that's my first line of
resistance. We came back up by two
points, then start coming back down. I
got another eight here, and the market
starts working its way down. Just as
this market's working its way up. Look,
I got seven here, I got four here. Then
when we hit this high, come off,
made a new high, come off within a tick
there, and keep going up.
All right. What do we got here? So, you
know, high of the day here, start coming
off, going sideways right before this
big sell-off. What do I see as I start
seeing single print here, single print
here, single print here?
You know, five, four, three.
I'm not saying it's cuz it's lesser each
time it's more important, but you know,
really what I'm looking at is small
print, small print, small print.
Knowing that we hit this high, came off,
made a move back up. There's lack of
buying interest here. Come off again,
make another move, lack of buying
interest, come off, lack of buying
interest, and boom, market just falls
over. Down, down, down, down, down.
Down here you got a
single digit here. You know, even on
this move down, you got a couple more
single digits. You know, maybe you're
short, and then it gets this little bit
of a bounce here, and you think, "Ah, I
think I should cover it." You know,
people go, "Ah, I don't know what to do.
You know, do I cover it or not?" And
then you start seeing single digit,
single digit, small prints. Yeah, you
know, you can hold it, all right? You
can get a little squeeze a little bit
more out of the
the trade. Now, the summary content now,
you know, this is nothing unique to our
software, but I just want to talk about
it a bit cuz
yeah, any order flow software is going
to have it, but not a lot of people know
how to use it. Um, it's delta, max
delta, min delta, volume. That's what I
look at. But, you can also look at the
uh ask volume, the bid volume, the
cumulative delta, cumulative delta
divided by volume, and total volume. So,
this is what I look at, all right? This
is what it looks like down here. Delta,
it's on the bottom, max delta, min
delta, volume. That's what I focus on.
You know, just make it a little easier.
Delta, max delta, min delta, volume. To
me, me personally in my trading, that's
what I look at. Now, you, you know, you
may want more information. You can see
down here, you got
ask volume, bid volume. The difference
is going to be your delta. Now, you got
max delta, you've got min delta,
cumulative delta. Some people like to
look at cumulative delta.
Um,
I don't. Um, and then there's a reason
for it. The reason being
I I just find it lags a bit, um,
you know, in in
you know, there there's people who are
going to say, "Well, you know, I I can't
I'm not going to take a trade. I'm not
going to take a short if the
cumulative delta is positive." Okay,
well, you can see here on this move up,
this big move up,
cumulative, you know, it's positive
delta, right? Cumulative delta keeps
growing, growing, growing. Then the
market starts coming off.
By the time this market, you know, for
it to get down to um, you know, it's
to get down to a a negative delta, all
right? You're going to basically
point I'm trying to make is you're going
to cut yourself out of trades, potential
trades, because you're you're sticking
to this rule that I can't take any
shorts is if cumulative delta is
positive. Um, you know, it just doesn't
make sense because yeah, it's going to
be positive for for time if there's been
a big move up or negative cumulative
delta for a long time, there's been a
big strong move down.
Right? Especially if you're putting in
big delta numbers. So,
again, that's why I don't use it.
There's some people I know that use it
in in other markets. This is E-minis.
You know,
they get value in it. So, that's why we
have it there. Cumulative delta and
volume.
Uh my programmer uses this. I don't use
it. It's basically it's the cumulative
delta divided by I believe the volume
for the bar.
Um
but he just wanted it in there for his
own use. Volume for the bar and
cumulative volume for the day. I just
look at the volume for the bar. That's
what I'm really interested in like this
here. So, I know if it's heavier than
normal or light. You know, these big
contracts like E-minis. Yeah, you know,
it's it's it's just information I'm not
going to look at. So, I I just
uncheck it there. You could check what
you want to look at here. All right? If
you want to see delta, you check it. Max
delta, min delta, volume.
So,
again, you know, ask bid delta, max
delta, min delta, cumulative volume,
cumulative delta divided by volume,
volume, and cumulative volume. Now,
people are going to say
um you know, what's max delta? What's
min delta? Max delta is what
the most positive delta was in a bar.
Right? Min delta is the opposite, the
most negative delta in a bar. Now, the
delta is the final delta where when the
bar closed, what was the delta? And
there's relationships between these um
delta, max delta, min delta.
Um I I go more in depth to it on the uh
delta course.
Now, unfinished business
is when a bar has unfinished auction.
And you look for the market to come back
to that level. That's how people
when they first started noticing
unfinished business in a footprint
chart, you know, it was back in the
mid-2000s when
you know, the market traded more rangy.
Now, with Trump in office, the market is
just bonkers most of the time, but um
you know, when market is
you know, relatively quiet, even during
Obama's time, you know, you
you'd have these days in the S&P's where
it's just like uh
you know, some days are a five-point
range, basically, or a 10-point range
would be a lot some days. And you know,
that's when I think unfinished business
is more effective. And unfinished
business,
I think a lot of people don't understand
and and use it incorrectly. I had the
good fortune that one of the original
guys
that noticed unfinished business, you
know, he
he reached out to me once, and we're
talking about this, and he he was
telling me, you know, how they started
using it, you know, how they used it was
um you know, they were looking for the
market to come back there relatively
soon, like within an hour, you know,
even 30 minutes. You know, if it's over
an hour, forget about it. Um you know,
books, I see people now looking drawing
out these unfinished business lines
over, you know,
3 hours, 4 hours. Um you know, it's
really lost its effectiveness. You know,
that's that's
one of the things that um you know, when
you're trading order flow, you know,
there's a shelf life for certain pieces
of information in the order flow.
But
you know, even though as I say that, I'm
I the glass ceiling is being shattered
because we are working on tools that um
you know, order flow
how to use order flow on 30-minute
charts.
Um that's, you know, tools
more advanced tools, but um
you know,
keep tuned tune in to the channel
um the YouTube channel for more on that
later. But
you know, the unfinished business on the
order flow trader, it's going to be at
the bottom of a red bar, at the top of a
green bar.
And you can see you can go into the
setting, you click here if you want to
detect unfinished business.
You click this button. You can draw the
broken levels if you want, You what
colors you want the lines. But just
really quick, this is what it's going to
look like here. This is this setting
here, detect unfinished business.
And you can see here,
right? It's drawing that line out there.
Right? It's at the top of a green bar.
So, you see here, 211 212, right? So, at
this point, this market was 30300
and a 3009.5
bid offered at the
3009 and 3/4. But it didn't trade 3/4.
So, you got this unfinished business cuz
it was bid offered up there.
You see how the market came back, tried
to come back to those levels a few
times, you know, here,
here, before eventually uh rejecting
those levels and moving down.
Now, you can draw the broken levels.
Now, I don't recommend this cuz you're
going to end up with a boatload of lines
for broken levels as well as the normal
levels. Like you can see here, right? It
came back up here. You
You know, here you had unfinished
business
um on this red bar.
It came back, came back, came back, and
it just keeps the line there. That's uh
too messy for my taste. I I don't use
unfinished business. I I just find
there's there's so much other wealth of
information out there.
Um but you know, we have it in there
because I do have some users that
like to look at unfinished business. Me
personally, I I honestly I can say I
don't look at unfinished business. I
don't like to have so many lines
necessarily drawn on my chart.
Now, the next thing I talk about is
volume imbalances. And
volume imbalance is So, you can see
where market imbalances appear on
markets
based on percentage you determine,
right? And this is
um
you know, basically, you know, you can
see inside the bar, right? There's red
numbers, and then there's blue numbers
for buying imbalances, red numbers for
selling imbalances inside the bar. I'm
not talking about the numbers above or
below. I'm talking about the numbers
inside the bar.
And again, you can change the colors. I
like blue for aggressive buying. I like
red for aggressive selling.
Now,
imbalance cluster is the zone that's
drawn out. So, if you have a stacked
imbalance like here, right? It's green,
right? It's a stack buying imbalance.
Red for a stack selling imbalance.
Again, you can change that to whatever
color you like. Um
you know, I I've always used I used to
use green numbers instead of blue, but I
changed to blue cuz it just stands out
more and
um but I never change the uh the what
the stack imbalance color is. I still
keep it at light green.
Um five is the number of um
bars out you can you know, you can
decide how many bars out you want it 1 2
3 4 5. Now, the reason I have it at five
cuz I'm just looking at this as near
near term support or resistance. I'm not
looking at this as a level that I'm
going to trade around
the rest of the day or 3 hours. Really,
if I'm trading this stacked imbalance,
I'm looking for that move to happen over
the next couple of bars. If it doesn't
happen,
things in the order flow have probably
changed and I don't want to be long
anymore, okay? Now,
uh where is it here? Imbalance opacities
is how dark you want the colors to be.
You know, do you want it darker or not?
You know, 50% I find is fine cuz I still
want to read the numbers in there. If
you put it at 100, it'll just
color everything and you can't read the
the numbers inside.
Um cluster size is five. So, if you want
to look at stack imbalance three rather,
imbalance cluster size set to three. So,
you're looking at stacked imbalances of
three or more. If you want to look at
stacked imbalances of two
or more, you can set it to two, right?
This is set to three.
So, I had set at two, I'd have a stacked
imbalance selling imbalance right here,
another one right here.
Um I'd have a stack buying imbalance
right here.
Again, it's up to you how you want to
use it. Um, you know, three I find is,
you know, I hate to say industry
standard, but it's, you know, basically
the industry standard. Now, and talking
about industry standard is the imbalance
trigger 400. That's four to one.
Okay? Now,
most people use four to one. You don't
have to use four to one. You could use
five to one, which would be 500. You
could use 10 to one, which is 1,000, you
know, but there are people that that use
other numbers besides 400. I use 400 as
my default. Most my charts have it. I do
look at charts with it set to 1,000, you
know, which is 10 to one.
Now,
what I'm going to talk about also is
imbalance bar outline and imbalances
in the bar threshold, which is this part
here. And this is what I call multiple
imbalances, right? So, you can see here,
right? These are stacked imbalances,
right? They're neatly stacked on top of
each other. You got 168 against five,
180 against five, 132 against 12, right?
That's all neatly stacked in there. Now,
here
you don't have a stacked imbalance. You
got 245 against four, 604 against 124,
221 against one.
Okay? This is a multiple imbalance,
right? Down here, you got a multiple
imbalance on a green bar, right? This
one's bullish. This one's bearish,
right? I don't differentiate the color
of the outline.
You have to look at the bar itself. So,
I know I got a multiple imbalances here.
27 against 150, 26 against 129, 81
against 415. It's a multiple buying
imbalance. This is on the low of the day
as well. I know I got a divergence right
here. That's what this is. When I see,
you know, multiple imbalances coming in
at the low of the day, that's a very
bullish sign.
And most of us are used to looking only
for stacked imbalances, but when you got
multiple imbalances in a bar, it's just
as important as stacked imbalances,
right? So, you got to look for those
things.
Now, it's also going to appear on a bar
that you have a stacked imbalance
because you have
three or more imbalances in the bar when
it's a stacked imbalance.
But, really, you know, you're going to
be looking for areas like I said, this
is a great example right down here on
the low. We're going to be looking for
multiple imbalances coming in, you know,
buying imbalances off the low like right
here. Right, this red line is your low
of the day.
Look at this bar here, right? You got 1
2 3 4 imbalances. They're not stacked
neatly on top of each other. You know,
there's regular order flow going
through.
But, you know, if you're buying it in
here, you can see how the market moved
up.
You know, here's another
example. This is stacked imbalances,
right? We're coming into the low. You
see the aggressive selling. You make the
new lows. Boom, you make your new lows.
You got stacked buying imbalance right
off the low. Boom, you're in the trade.
Go it starts going sideways here. Should
I get out or not? Well, you know what?
I've got multiple imbalances coming in
in this bar. You know, I think I'll hold
it a little bit. And you're rewarded
with a few extra points out of the
trade.
So, that's how you use these tools,
right? It's not
just well, I'm only going to be looking
for a signal at a higher or the low.
But, once you're in a trade, right? You
start putting the stuff together, right?
Look at this bar here, right? You got
this bar.
You know, if you're you're long from
here and you're next thing you know,
you're trading five points higher. Do I
stay in the trade? Do I get out? Well, I
can do some analysis. I got multiple
buying imbalances, which is bullish. Um
you know, I got the single print down
here, the small print here, which is
bullish.
You know, yeah, maybe it's worth a while
keeping in the position. And you know,
you can get an extra two three points
out of that trade.
You know, here's
more. All right, it's a 15-minute chart.
Crude oil 15-minute chart. Okay?
So, you got your stacked selling
imbalance here.
Boom, market came up, came right up to
that level. Sellers came back in. You
got a single print in here. So, you know
that traders are rejecting these higher
prices. And the market comes off.
I won't to higher prices, but traders
are rejecting this move back up
here with this um small digit printing
here. I I can see the box, that's how I
know it's a small digit print. And you
see how this market sold off nicely down
into new lows. Another 100 another
dollar in this move down here.
Now, you know, a feature that I just
talked about is the multiple imbalances.
And
it's not available in other flows other
order flow software as far as I know.
You know, I'm sure you know, a lot of
people have copied many of my tools and
put it in their own order flow
softwares.
And you know, it's funny cuz they give
it these fancy names like, oh, this is a
imbalance algo detector
nonsense stuff like this the multiple
imbalance. You know, keep things simple
so you can understand what it is, you
know, I I
I always laugh when I see these names
for stuff people come up with, you know,
oh, order flow tracker sequencer this
and that, you know, it's just you know,
if it's a multiple imbalance, just say
you know, it's a it's a multiple
imbalance. You got more than three
imbalances in the bar that are not
stacked on top of each other.
But again, you got to look for them at
areas
where
you're going to look to trade around,
right? I'm at a low of the day and I see
multiple imbalances coming in. That's a
good sign, that's a bullish sign if it's
multiple buying imbalances.
That's what I want to be looking for,
right? I'm not going to necessarily
looking for a reason to get short around
the low of the day. I'll be looking for
reasons to be getting long at the low of
the day and if I have
um you know,
multiple buying imbalances off the low,
that's a bullish sign. And you'll
notice, right? You're going to get it
often triggers earlier. This is
um you know, something I'll share with
you.
Often times, you don't get stacked
imbalances
um as often as you get multiple them
earlier. You're going to get You know,
people are just looking for stacked
imbalance,
right? You're getting you see you have
it here, okay? Yeah, oh, this is good,
you know, we come in off our low. Our
low is down here at 30 uh you know, what
is this? 3005.
But, up here 3009, 3010 is where your
stacked buying imbalance comes in. Where
would you rather be long from? 3010 or
3006?
It's an extra four points you could have
got
in on before the stacked buying
imbalance, all right? And it this
multiple imbalance
tool really gets you in trades a lot
earlier and gets you in trades that a
lot of people honestly aren't going to
see at all.
And you can see here at the high of the
day, divergence, ratio, boom, multiple
imbalances next bar, multiple
imbalances. Do you think this market's
going any higher? No, it's dominated by
aggressive selling.
You got three imbalances in this bar,
three imbalances in this bar, you got
small digits, small digits. Again, you
got your divergence, you got your ratio,
which I'll talk about shortly. Um you
know,
it's
get short, you know, go
take the money out of your piggy bank,
put it on getting short here.
And you can see how the market made a
nice, you know, five-point move off of
that.
Again, 15-minute No, it's a five-minute
chart.
Um crude oil. Crude oil 15-minute chart
is probably can't fit on a screen, you
won't be able to read it.
But, look at that.
Off of low of the day here down here,
boom, multiple
imbalances, one, two, three spread out
in there. And you could catch this nice
move up, you know, it's nice move from
5750 up to, you know, 58 bucks. Here you
got a bearish prominent point of control
up there.
Now, the volume profile, I mean, most
traders are familiar with um market
profile and volume profile to a certain
extent, and we have it on our charts.
I honestly can say I don't have it on my
charts
anymore. I I used to use it a lot, and
this is
the way I would use it is
you know, on trend days it would really
be very revealing to me what where the
value areas for the day, where the point
of control was, if it was migrating
lower, if it was a trend day down, or
migrating higher if it's trend day up.
But,
you know, I don't trade the whole day
anymore. You know, when I trade, it's
it's for a couple hours
in the morning, maybe a couple hours
uh after lunch.
So, you know, I'm not really so fixated
so much on the profile cuz I'm not
looking at it all day long.
Now,
what the volume profile allows you to do
is see
see the day's volume profile plotted on
the chart, identify where the market is
trading relative to today's point of
control. And again, you know, point of
control, uh value area high,
value area low is also areas you can
trade around. You know, you can see the
low volume nodes, high volume nodes. And
you can see it in here, volume profile.
You can display it on the right-hand
side or the left-hand side. Default is
left,
but you can put it on the right-hand
side if you want.
Um you can also choose to display it or
not. I have it unchecked here, so it
doesn't display. Volume, you know, you
can see the volume on the that was
traded on the ask, volume traded on the
bid.
Total volume colors, um and width and
pixels. So, this is what it looks like.
You know, this is it on the
um
left-hand side. This is it on the
right-hand side.
Again, you know, the right-hand side.
And you can see, right? This is when the
market reopened one night.
And I can see, you know, right away
here, you know, I got resistance right
here, right above this level. You know,
I'd be looking to get short.
And I'll as I know that
everything is starting to move move
lower, you know, I I would expect this
market to go down.
You know, I can see where the low
volumes areas are. So, if we're trading
up here, and I'm short, you know, I I
might have a target down in here. And if
we start breaking through that, you
know, I I know my
point of control for the day is down
here, or this volume down here is going
to be um an area of support if we come
back down to that level. You know,
there's
You know, a friend of mine is a guy Dale
from Trader Dale. You know, if you
really want to
take a good course on order flow uh not
order flow, volume profile.
He's actually wrote a book on it. You
can get it on Amazon. You can actually
download it for free, I think, on
Kindle.
Or for like five bucks, you can order it
for a printed version. I got the printed
version. It's nice, you know, it's a
very nicely well-written book and he
trades volume profile on forex and
futures. So,
it's you know, again, you know, Trader
Dale.
He's also got a profile tool that he
sells.
But, if you want to learn more about
trading the volume profile, um you know,
he's a good
place to go to to learn about that.
Now, the volume ratio, right? Now, this
is like my bread and butter.
Um and this is the legacy indicator
which has been copied by many other
order flow software out there.
Literally, after I released my software
within 6 months, I probably got A lot of
my users were messaging me saying, "Hey,
you know, this other company um
shish, I can't even remember the name.
Um
added it to them. Even Sierra Charts
added it to them. But, you know what?
It's It's like pointless because you
know, this is a tool that I created for
my own trading. But, again, it goes back
to what I was saying earlier, you know,
where people add stuff to their software
just so they can say they have it. But,
you know, if they don't understand the
logic behind it or why
I have it in my software and how to use
it, it's kind of pointless, you know? I
mean, yeah, I could add, you know, MACD
or I don't use that garbage on my
charts.
You know, um
I'm not going to say, "Oh, yeah, I also
got MACD on here." Well,
well, for what, you know? It's It's not
a useful tool cuz I don't use it. I'm no
expert in it. I'm not saying that it is
a useful tool. But, it's like, you know,
people want to put more and more into it
without understanding the reasoning
behind it, why it's used. Now, this is
how I used to trade. I
used to use a calculator until I got,
you know, and and use my head. I could
do the rough calculations, just this
borderline numbers sometimes. And really
what I'm looking for is two things, a
ratio bounds high and a ratio bounds
low. Okay? Now, a ratio bounds high
indicates price exhaustion. Ratio bounds
low indicates price defense. And you can
see the settings here, 28. So, if
there's a ratio above 28, that indicates
price exhaustion.
Ratio bounds low.
It indicates price defense. So, it's
below 6.69,
basically below one. Okay? This one's
basically above 25. All right?
Now, the numbers I use are 28 and 69 cuz
I refined them over the years. I used to
use 25 and one, but um now I use uh 28
and 0.69. Just to make it a little bit
finer. Um and I've stuck to these
numbers since, gosh, for 5 years
already. I said, you know, when I used
to do it manually, I used 25 and I used
one.
Now, the ratio font is 17, so it's a
little bit bigger than the normal
um volume footprint bid ask numbers.
And it's blue. So, if it's above 28 or
below 0.69, the number's going to be
blue. And these numbers appear above and
below the bar.
So, you can see if it's black number,
right? Some numbers are black. If it's a
red candle, it's going to appear above.
If it's a green candle, it's going to
appear below. Now, if it's above the
threshold, like here's 50.85, that's
above 28, that's a blue number. 44.9 is
a blue number. 8.8
is between 28 and 0.69, so that's a
black number. Same with 6.617.
It's also a black number.
Now, the black numbers are just your
normal, you know, is the normal order
flow. Okay?
And the blue numbers indicate that
there's price rejection or price
exhaustion, it's the same thing. Price
rejection, price exhaustion.
And um or if it's a ratio balance low,
indicating um
price defense.
So, you can see here as this market is
going down, you tend to see the blue
numbers on top, right? Notice as the
market's going down, you don't see very
many blue numbers or any blue numbers
below the bars.
Right? That's one way of keeping you in
the trade if you're short already.
You know, should I cover it? Well, you
know, I still see the market's under
pressure,
right? Cuz I've got blue numbers above
the bars. Now, there's
um you know, ways to use these blue
numbers, which I'll get to shortly.
May you see as the market starts going
up, what do we got here? Lo and behold,
I got a blue number,
right? Right off the low of the day.
This red line is the low of the day.
This is actually a divergence here at
the low and I got a ratio, which I'll
get into shortly.
May you see as the market is selling
off, the blue numbers are going to be
above the bar.
Blue, blue, blue. You don't see any blue
numbers below the bar till you get down
here.
You got a blue number, the market starts
going back up. Now, the thing is it's a
ratio, okay? Don't get caught up in how
big or how small the ratio is. As long
as it's a blue number, right? Don't
think that well, it's 112, so that's
stronger than 28.64.
No, as long as it's a blue number, it's
within the ratio
or
it's
qualified under the ratio terms that,
you know, I don't care if it's 112 or if
it's 29, okay? As long as it's blue,
that's all that matters to me.
Cuz it's again, it's it's a ratio,
right? It's not actual volume numbers
inside the bar.
See, you see here, blue, blue, blue,
blue on the way up.
You know, on the way down, you're seeing
blue on top of the red candles, right?
Till the market flips here. Now, this is
a set up
This is what I call the three-in-a-row
set-up, 1 2 3, ratio ratio ratio,
a pullback on the fourth bar,
and it's coming in between these two
point of controls, then I got the green
bar. It's nice to get this ratio here,
but I'd just be I'd be I'm fine if this
wasn't a bullish ratio.
Well, really when I see three in a row
like this and a pullback between the two
point of controls of the third bar and
the second bar, and this is where I'll
be getting long here, and it's a nice
trade. You can see it back up there.
And again, you know, you see this move,
right? What do you see down here? You
see you're at your low of the day. Okay,
you know, I've got my bearish ratios
here, 81 743.
I got a divergence. I got a bullish
ratio. I got another bullish ratio.
Another bullish ratio. Another bullish
ratio. You know, really the trade set-up
to have is is right here, the divergence
and the ratio.
Let's say, you know, you know what? I
don't believe this low is low enough,
you know, this reason we buying is is
enough. I need something else. Well,
when you're still hanging around and I'm
seeing a bullish ratio here, I'm seeing
price defense here, and we come back
test that level. See what I was talking
about? There's price defense. You can
see it in here early in this bar. Then
when you come back down
in this bar, look at the amount of
volume that's traded, 4,000, 2 and 1/2
thousand. Here you had a very lighter
lighter much lighter volume, you know,
129 429.
But, you can see how the the market was
defending this area right in here. We
did get through it by a tick, traded 115
contracts, then it started going back
up. Bullish ratio, bullish ratio.
Right? Came
up here to a bearish ratio. Market came
off a little bit.
Prominent point of control, bullish one.
Small digit print. Bullish ratio,
bullish ratio, bullish ratio. I mean,
look at the market made a big massive
move up all the way up to new highs. New
highs, new highs, new highs, new highs
before where get a divergence up here,
and the market came off.
Now,
when an order flows delta divergence,
which I discussed earlier, right? That
was like the first one I discussed in
this video,
occurs with a ratio that we were the
result is a powerful trade setup. And
you can see here, right? Here you have a
divergence by itself, nothing. Market
went up. Divergence by itself, nothing.
Market went up. Divergence, but a
bearish ratio, market sold off. This is
my favorite trade. I'm always looking
for these trades.
I wish I could get 10 of them a day,
you know, even if just half were right,
you know, I'm fine with it because I
know where is my stop. It's right above
the high, or if it was a a buy,
be right below the low.
So, this is a bearish ratio This is a
bearish signal right up here at the high
of the day.
Just as here, bearish signal right up at
the high of the day.
Look at those moves. Look at this move.
5-minute chart.
1-minute chart.
4 range chart.
Right? I mean, look at this. From These
are nice moves, right? Those are very
powerful trades. And
again, you know, what difference with um
the order flows trader software than
most order flows software out there is
the divergence way we look at
divergence, right? We just don't look
for a new or equal low with positive
delta. We also look at the price action
of the bar. Is the bar reversing, right?
We're at our low, but if this is a red
candle, market is trading down, even
though I got positive delta,
price action isn't confirming it, you
know? With our software, you got to be
closing higher than where you open for a
buy,
right? Cuz you're not reversing anything
if the bar is is closed down.
And And that's one of the big
differences. I don't think I talked
about that when I was talking about
delta divergence.
But you know, again, you know, this is a
tool that it's available in our
software.
Some people sell a diverse simple
divergent software where it just picks a
new just at a new or equal high or new
equal low. In this case, it's got
positive delta. That's all they're
looking for. They're not looking at the
price action. So, they're going to be
wrong a lot. You know, and I think
that's a big mistake.
So,
you know, by now
you should understand why the Order
Flows Trader is a different and much
better than
tool than than just a basic order flow
footprint chart, right? It's difference
between a pocket knife and a Swiss Army
knife. You know, what would you rather
have if you're out in the woods? Can you
survive with a pocket knife? Yes, you
can.
But, life will be a lot better if you
got a lot of tools, you know.
I don't know what you're going to do
with the corkscrew out in the wilderness
unless you bring a bottle of champagne,
but, you know, you never know. You know,
you never know.
You know, markets are dynamic, right? A
trader has to be able to adapt to
different market conditions, right? You
need tools that will help you see what's
really happening in the market through
the order flow. You know, the Order
Flows Trader has the tools built into it
that allow the trader to accurately
interpret what's happening in the order
flow.
Again, you know, there are two ways to
become a successful trader. One, try and
figure everything out for yourself.
Okay? It can take you years and tens of
thousands of dollars trying to do it all
by yourself. And I don't just mean tens
of thousands of dollars spent on books
and courses. I mean money lost in the
markets.
Okay? And that's the worst part, you
know, we everyone always talks about,
"Yeah, I blew up my account three
times."
For what? You know, if you blow up an
account once, that should be enough, you
know? Ideally, you should never blow up
your account.
Or two,
you can speed up your learning by
getting the Order Flows Trader software
and education package for a one-time
fee, you know? There are thousands of
people out there claiming to be experts
who want you to think they can solve all
your problems with some easy fix. Oh,
just buy the software, it's going to
solve all your problems. No, you know,
the way you become a successful trader
is you learn how to trade. You learn how
to read the market, right? I didn't
survive 20 years in this business by
buying some indicator and running it on
a on on my Bloomberg. You know, no. I
became you know, I last 20 years in this
industry cuz I learned how to read the
market very early on in my career. I
learned on the floor the importance of
understanding order flow and
understanding what orders mean when they
hit the market and actually trade. You
know, people will say, "Well, order flow
is not the volume footprint is not
trading order flow." They
think
the dome is you know, the the only way
to read order flow. that. You know,
honestly, go search up spoofing on the
internet, right? If you don't believe
me, you'll see cases being tried today
in court. You know,
CFTC is coming down on people for this
stuff. And even you know, I think last
year they convicted
15 people for spoofing the market. And
this has been going on every year. They
get, you know, a dozen people at least.
And you know, you can imagine how many
people are not getting caught.
So,
you know, if if you're sitting there
staring at a dome and you're thinking
what you're seeing is legitimate, you
know, maybe 90% is, but there's still
people out there thinking they're going
to be able to pull the wool over
someone's eyes and get away with this
stuff. Ultimately, they're going to get
caught. You know, the best way to trade
is be a trader. Learn how to trade. You
know, and unfortunately,
rather for most traders, you know, they
want to start at the top, you know? But
you got to get the foundation. You got
to start learning
about order flow by
watching the order flow. Unfortunately,
there there's no quick shortcut, you
know? The only shortcut that I can offer
you is, you know, courses and software
that will put the order flow in an
easy-to-read format and only and I teach
you in the courses how to read the order
flow. Now, this is the time where
everyone's going to say, "Oh, here it
comes the pitch." No, I'm not got
nothing to sell you in this video. This
is it. You know, if you're interested in
order flow, go to my website. I got a
lot of videos. You can learn more there.
But, that's it. That's what this
end of this video. I just wanted to make
this one to show you guys
um the power of the order flows trader
and how it can help you in your trading.
So, thanks everyone for your time. This
this presentation went on a bit longer
than I anticipated. So, it's an hour and
15 minutes. Basically,
um
but I covered, you know, pretty much
everything I wanted to cover so you can
understand
how to read the order flow using tools
that are available to you. And these
tools are not available,
unfortunately, in other software. So,
thanks everyone and have a great day.
Bye-bye.